okay we have a great show tonight and uh
wait a minute
i'm getting a zoom call i think
hey it's sarah silverman hi sarah hi
i just wanted to say congratulations
oh congratulations for what because
you're gonna be one of the
the first um group of people to get a a
coveted vaccination
no no i i don't think i'm one of the
first people to get a covid vaccine
that's not right
no you are i'm so happy because i love
you so much it is it's like
i have it on my phone right yeah okay
according to the cdc
healthcare workers emergency first
responders and people 65 and older will
be among the first to get the new
wait wait sarah you think i'm 65 or
older is this a bit are you doing a bit
right now
no we're not doing a bit i'm not 65
years old i'm nowhere near that
conan don't do this
don't do what look i get it i know this
business
is horrible to seniors but like don't
risk your life
for vanity that's crazy
i'm not risking my life i'm not 65 do i
look that old to you
i mean yeah no not now but the last time
i was at the studio i saw you you were
in the makeup chair for over two and a
half hours
that's what are you putting on
prosthetics what are you getting planet
of the apes
no i no i i'm just saying i'm i i get a
lot of makeup because i'm pale it's not
because i'm old
on your chest okay what i get done on my
chest before the show is none of your
business that's private
my point is i wasn't born in 1955.
well your spotify playlist says
otherwise
okay well whatever i just happen to like
to groove out to the oldies it's not a
big deal
a lot of young people do but i wasn't
born in
who was president in 1955 eisenhower
whoa that was fast you didn't even have
to think
yeah oh come on sarah a person can know
who was president before they were born
okay fine look i was i was just worried
about you
you know i love you if you say you're
not 65 you're not 65 that's
that's good enough for me okay
well thank you sarah and someday when i
am 65 i
hope we're still friends of course we
will be quick question when i say tick
tock what comes to mind
tick tock uh sound a clock makes why
anything else um
no okay well have a good show
conan love you
okay bye thanks sarah